hey guys how's it going today we're
gonna be making something so that we can
test out all four of these GoPro heroes
at the same time let's get started
[Applause]
looks like we have a little bit of a
problem because these two cases are not
the same we can make it work time to
attach these bad boys to those things
[Music]
now we need to open up my GoPro app and
connect all of these together so I can
make sure that the picture looks okay
and that everything's framed up all
right got one go prepared ready for
action
number two connected number three
connected and there we go we've got them
all connected to the GoPro app
all right we're finally getting
somewhere
the time is now we are hitting record on
234 everything is recording they're all
recording in 1080p at 60 frames a second
so let's pick them up and see what we
can see one of the first things that
I've noticed on the GoPro Hero black is
because of the image stabilization and
it definitely does crop off some of the
edges so you do lose a little bit of
that view these are all also set in wide
view so let's go see let's go test it
out this is so silly soon as I walk
around and test this out I'm gonna swap
this little cover for one of the
waterproof cases because these other
three are waterproof without a case I
think I need some sunglasses where's my
Sunny's I gotta put them on so you guys
will be able to see what you look like
in my reflection we think of us you
think this is cool my sisters are always
very supportive of my endeavors a little
bit windy right now let's see which one
picks up the worst of the wind wind test
wind test let's do a little introduction
shall we
oops this here is the GoPro Hero session
5 this here is the GoPro Hero session
this is the hero4 silver and this is the
GoPro Hero 5 baby this here is the GoPro
Hero 5 session this here is the GoPro
Hero 5 this is the GoPro Hero 4 silver
and this is the GoPro Hero session so
we're gonna switch out this Hero 4 and
put a waterproof case on it like I've
said in previous videos one of the best
parts about the session and the new Hero
5 is there already waterproof
I hope this still fits great it does ok
time to go in the pool this is the first
time that I'm gonna be going into the
pool with the hero 5 and the hero 5
session so who wants to go underwater
cuz I don't want to go underwater
yeah the waterproof oh gosh it's so cold
ok you guys ready to go in
[Music]
how's everything sounded how's
everything looking how's everything
sounded how's everything looking how's
everything sounded how's everything
looking and here we are the conclusion
which one's the best I have no idea if I
were to set all four of these cameras
right in front of me and judging by the
video that I saw and I was just going
out to vlog and I needed something that
I knew was gonna work and get the job
done and the audio was gonna be okay and
I didn't have to worry about sound
issues I would go with the hero for now
this one isn't waterproof but one of the
things that I found when I was vlogging
especially with the hero 5 for a day
just out and about there was a lot of
rustling sounds I feel like they moved
the microphone I'm even sure where the
microphone is on this thing well looks
like judging by the tap test that this
is the microphone and for whatever
reason the hero 5 seems to get a lot of
extra sound when you're moving around
and for me that bothers me a lot because
I'm vlogging and I don't have time to
worry about if the audio is gonna be
perfect on my vlog or not but this one
is definitely proved the test of hey the
audio is good I did have to worry about
the wind too much but when you put this
thing in a case the audio just turns
basically to crap so you can tell the
audio with the case and without the case
there's a huge difference it seems like
the microphone is a little bit more
sensitive on you or five versions so
even if you're just sitting there and
there is no noise there's definitely a
little bit more of kind of like a
rustling sound so you can definitely
hear more ambient noise on these guys
which could be why you hear less wind I
don't know I'm not sure I'm not
I'm going nuts I'm going crazy because
trying to figure out which one I like
the best is pretty difficult I'll say
this if you've never had a GoPro before
if you get any one of these GoPros
you're gonna definitely be happy with it
the interface on the five is so much
better though than the interface in any
of the previous versions I'm super
stressed out because I thought that by
the end of this video I'd have a
conclusion I'd be able to give you a
solid answer but really I think my solid
answer is you're gonna be happy with any
one of them I don't I just that's that's
really that's all I've got to say if you
are going from the hero 4 to the 5 just
note that there is a few audio
difference as far as the video quality I
mean it's all sort of similar I was
shooting in 1080p so clearly it's not
gonna look that much difference but if
you do want 4k you're gonna have to hop
up to some of the higher versions of the
GoPro but if you just want 1080 and you
just want to film and you just want to
have something just honestly you're
gonna be fine with any of these so I'm
gonna go because this decision was very
difficult for me I'm gonna go charge
these guys and I don't know just think
about think about life think about how
much I miss my camera because I dropped
it in the pool
[Music]
hi guys not working out the way that I
had
[Music]